the last week I was interviewed for an
upcoming publication and one of the
questions I was asked was what do you
think is really important right now that
is not getting the attention that it
deserves and my mind went immediately to
the courts and I hope that this part of
the interview makes it into the article
that should be published later this week
I'll make sure to share it with you when
it is because while impeachment
continues to get attention which it
should as Trump's foibles overseas with
our allies continue to be discussed
which they should the courts are
increasingly under the oversight of
Trump appointed judges and they are
going to ruin this country for decades
to come
now Donald Trump in conjunction with the
truly sickening disgusting hyper
partisan Clown Kentucky senator Mitch
McConnell have been working together to
confirm what they have a goal of being a
hundred and eighty-two judges by the end
of this year federal judges who are
really important to our judicial system
and this gets very little attention
these are lifetime appointments Donald
Trump is on track to put nearly twice as
many of these judges as President Obama
had at this point in his presidency the
Supreme Court picks get a lot of
attention and they should but most cases
don't get to the Supreme Court the
number of cases that in the aggregate
these federal court judges are going to
decide on Dwarfs by orders of magnitude
the number of cases that the Supreme
Court is going to decide on lots of the
judges that are being nominated and
actually confirmed are getting the
rating of straight-up not qualified from
the American Bar Association one example
is Fortas 46 year old Lawrence Van Dyke
who was just confirmed by the Mitch
McConnell run Senate every single one of
these appointments is terrible but there
are also tipping points that go beyond
just another judge here or another judge
there and I apologize for punching my
mic I'm just getting very wound up about
this another example the Ninth Circuit
Court as a whole is historically a
left-leaning
court there are 29 seats on that court
13 are currently Republican seats 10 of
those 13 Republican seats are trump
appointed even the Ninth Circuit Court
is increasingly trumpian and Republicans
are united in favor of these horrible
and often unqualified judges for example
everyone other than Republican senator
Susan Collins voted to confirm Sarah
Pitt liqu Sarah Pitt liqu is completely
and totally opposed to abortion she
considers the destruction of an embryo a
quote killing she considers that a
killing
she has never tried a single case but
she will have a lifetime seat on a
United States District Court in Missouri
she was also rated not qualified by the
American Bar Association now I could go
on and on with examples but the big
picture is what matters here first of
all this is a reminder once again not
that we needed it if you thought Hillary
would have been just as bad as Trump no
one should listen to you ever again and
the courts were high on the list of why
that was a very very incorrect analysis
at the time and I've continued to make
it since now the worldwide embarrassment
the bogus trade war that's also on the
list but the courts were at the top of
the list from the beginning number two
this is a reminder that Donald Trump's
impact will continue long beyond his
presidency this is something we've been
talking about lately and the courts are
a big part of that as well
now I hesitate to call impeachment a
distraction from this because number one
impeachment is really important even if
it fails impeachment is a congressional
duty when the facts warrant it you
impeach you don't say well it's gonna
distract from this that or the other
thing but number two the judge stuff
would be happening with or without
impeachment and other than no taking
back the Senate we would have little way
to stop what is going on with judges but
there could be more coverage because if
every time one of these completely and
totally unqualified judges was nominated
we had massive public outcry and
coverage on corporate media it might
shame the Trump administration into
nominating at least marginally more
qualified and less crazy people maybe
but the most important thing about this
is getting coverage so that it puts it
in people's minds as something to think
about when you consider who to vote for
in November of 2020 imagine that you
were one of those people who incorrectly
thought back in 2016
Trump Hillary whatever it's all the same
if you recognize that one of the areas
where that analysis was so wrong I mean
it was a weaponized argument it was so
wrong and toxic if you recognize that
with judges that argument fell very
short if that is repeated now it would
be in your mind when you think about
2020 and maybe it gets you not to stay
home but to go out and vote for somebody
who will help remove Donald Trump where
your vote will help remove Donald Trump
that is why we have to make sure people
understand the long lasting impact of
this we have to continue to repeat that
this issue of judges every month is
getting worse I think it was two months
ago on the bonus show he said 25% of
judges at some level I don't remember
exactly what it was have now been
selected by Donald Trump Donald Trump's
judgment about who to select when he
doesn't give it to some other
conservative group or special interest
group and actually is picking people
himself it's disastrous
it's absolutely and completely
disastrous so we can't forget about this
I hope it's part of this article that is
coming out about the David Pakman show
in a few days which I will share with
you on social media and I'm going to
renew my effort to continue talking
about this on the show before you go on
to the next video please hit subscribe
and like we are trying to figure out
what this will do for helping us in
YouTube's algorithm I will report back
to you but please before you go on to
the next video please subscribe to our
Channel and hit that like button thank
you